Marvel didn't wait too long to give us
our first look at the upcoming the
Eternals concept art for the flick which
will be in the second film in the MCU
phase four was recently released online
it depicts a quartet of the ancient
beings known as Celestials walking
across the surface of a barren planet
we've been introduced to these things
just a couple of times before once in
each of the guardians of the galaxy
movies and Guardians vol 1 our heroes
travel to the mining colony of Exeter to
meet with the collector who had some
knowledge to impart about the Infinity
stones exit r is situated within nowhere
which is actually the severed head of a
deceased celestial a later scene also
seem to showcase a look at a celestial
as it uses the power stone to
effortlessly destroy an entire planet
these carriers can use this
civilizations like wheat in guardians
volume two we got our first proper
introduction to one of the all-powerful
entities in the form of ego the Living
Planet who was revealed to be the father
of Pizza quelle ego didn't look a lot
like the Celestials pictured but we can
assume that Celestials come in all
shapes and sizes plus we can assume from
egos ability to masquerade as a human
the Celestials can assume other forms if
need be in Marvel lore the Celestials
existed before virtually any other form
of sentient life in the universe
millions of years ago they were
responsible for the creation of the
Eternals near immortal super-powered
humanoids and their polar opposite race
the deviants which are essentially the
eternal equivalent of mutants the two
races have been logged in struggle for
centuries but the Eternals tasked with
defending earth from the deviants
conquest and thus far in the MCU we
haven't met any Eternals that we know of
but we have met one deviant Thanos the
mad Titan who embarked on a quest to
collect all six Infinity stones and wipe
out half of all life in the universe
carries a deviant gene in Marvel Comics
it's not yet known to what extent that
Celestials will figure into the
narrative of the Eternals marvel's head
honcho Kevin Feige
has hinted that the flesh could be an
epoch spanning tens of thousands of
years so we may only get a look at them
in the form of some exposition on the
ancient history of the universe
as for the Eternals themselves we at
least have an idea of what a team that
will be featured in the movie will look
like thanks to marvel's recent panel at
San Diego comic-con 2019 the entire
primary cast was announced of the event
and it includes Richard Madden as Icarus
the leader of the Flex team of heroes
Angele
joleigh escena also known as Asura who
and the comments have been known to
consult with deviants Kumail Nanjiani as
Kingo who took up residence in Japan
thousands of years ago and learned the
ways of the samurai lurid red lavas
Macari an expert mechanical engineer and
speedster Brian Tyree Henry as Fastow's
a master weaponsmith salma hayek as a
jack who has spent most of her thousands
of earthly years in siberia finally
young Leah McHugh a sprite a trickster
who has forever stuck with the
appearance of a preteen child the
Eternals begins shooting next month so
hopefully it won't be too long before
some unofficial set photos of the stars
in costume arrive of course there will
probably be plenty of these interests
and little hints and revelations that
will come trickling out in the wake of
marvel's epic comic-con panel we'll keep
our eye out for them and keep you
up-to-date check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite superheroes are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]